so we have the story that came up a
little while ago from military.com
dozens of house democrats call on biden
to give up soul nuclear launch authority
this is crazy but it shouldn't be uh it
shouldn't be unexpected
joe biden is he's not all with it see
that's fair to say there's been reports
that kamala harris has been doing his
job for him because he's been
napping in the sun as i predicted yeah
she's talking to foreign leaders on his
behalf or whatever
and now they're saying we we think joe
biden should give up soul power to
launch nuclear weapons
and you know what i agree i agree i
don't think a senile or crackpot
should be holding nuclear football give
it up to who to open it up to
other people now that's a problem who
are the who are these other people maybe
you know what this is this is the
problem of having you know
a president who's in only because people
hated the other guy you know they
clearly right now you've got all the
democrats complaining well not all of
them sorry
all of the progressives complaining
about biden some of the democrats
but many of them just saying biden can
do no wrong right
you get a president who's based on
hating the other guy you
and and he's basically what's the
difference you know a lot of people say
like
you know he's going to do a lot of the
same foreign policy things actually
doing worse people are worried now we're
going to lose this piece we're
developing in the middle east
he's going to destabilize everything but
i'm sorry he is he is a senior old
crackpot
who was elected without the ability to
be president and now democrats are
saying he should give up
the sole power of the nuclear duty just
bombed syria well i
okay let me just get this out really
quick i don't know much about this
bombing of syria i read some mainstream
news articles from nbc and some other
and they were like
it's in retaliation to iran okay
obviously nbc is going to say that the
other one was
oh this might this is actually a
perverse way of improving diplomatic
relations with iran
because it's going to be forcing them to
the whatever
it's sickening i'm sorry well so let me
read some of the story from military.com
they say nearly three dozen house
democrats are urging president joe biden
to relinquish his sole authority to
order the launch of nuclear weapons
arguing that no single person should
wield apocalyptic military power
they say vesting one person with this
authority entails real risks
past presidents have threatened to
attack other countries with nuclear
weapons
or exhibited behavior that causes other
officials to express concerns
about the president's judgment according
to the letter which was spearheaded
by california reps jim jimmy panetta and
ted liu now interestingly
nancy pelosi tried doing this with
donald trump
uh i believe it was what like after
november yeah she went to
the joint chiefs i believe and she said
block trump's ability to order missile
strikes and they said ma'am that would
be a military coup we can't do that
the commander-in-chief has the ability
to fire the nukes
they're taking this away who would get
it it sounds to me
like look it's gonna say as cliche as
possible
all of these things are just ripping
this country into a million pieces
that's it well you know i never agree
with politicians
but these politicians make sense when
they're when they're talking about one
person on this earth that has the power
to press one button
and end the human race i'm sorry that's
a little bit too much power
when we're going to be engaging in
nuclear war we're engaging in a war
that's going to end
civilizations as we know it and i agree
with these democrats i never thought i
would say this but i agree on the merits
here
i don't agree uh i do i think it should
be decentralized i think definitely
there it shouldn't be one senile old man
who doesn't know where he is half the
time sometimes so that's
that's a problem of joe biden but then
the issue is you're creating
exponentially more vulnerabilities with
each individual you'll give the ability
to press a button
let's put it this way you've got joe
bunn as a senior little crackpot and
that freaks me out because he might
press the button and fire and knock they
said
donald trump was sporadic and erratic
and he might press the button and launch
a nuke that's still only two people
add ten more people and now you gotta
keep track of each and every one of them
who might launch
a nuke it'd be cool if you needed all of
them to agree well i think that that's
that's my question too is what
is the no that can't work either is the
alternative that we have just a bunch of
different
checks and balances if you will before
you can fire the nuke because
if that's the case yeah i guess i guess
that makes sense but if you start truly
federalizing the nuclear launch codes
and really start having that many
hands in the in the kitchen here's
what's going to happen the chinese
communist dictator you know xi jinping
is going to be like
i can launch all of the nuclear weapons
and they will have no time to retaliate
we win we win china will succeed
our cities will be fine and every nuke
will explode over america before they
even realize it
i guess you could automate a defensive
response and only you know federate the
the offensive line to like six people
they need to agree and turn the key
at the same time no but the issue
anything really convenient about just
having
well maybe so there's a reason why we
have a president who is the
commander-in-chief
it's so that we can respond quickly and
instantly to serious militaristic
threats
well maybe just add one more person
that's sound mind that's next to him
so this is the problem so what they give
us a crackpot president and use it as an
excuse to disseminate
a bunch when we gave the president the
power like that we didn't have
world-ending weapons at the push of a
bus true no wait we did when we created
the nuclear weapons we're like mr
president they're yours when we created
the office of the president and gave
them all that executive power we didn't
have nuclear weapons that could end the
human race so the problem is unless you
can answer me this
when china and russia know as autocrats
they can snap their fingers and blow up
the us and we can't respond
what defense do we have i don't think
biden could respond anyway it'd probably
be sleeping i know
i know you need to you need an automated
the problem is we are in a very
seriously dangerous position
because joe biden is a pathetic senile
old crackpot
i'm being a little hyperbolic no you're
right he's showing the cracks in the
system
so now you've got vladimir putin what is
he he's former kgb right yeah yeah and
he's riding on a horse with no shirt on
yeah
and he's he's so brutal i mean look at
the the dude who's trying to run against
him gets poisoned all the time yeah
all the time this guy is probably
laughing his ass off like
joe biden yeah what is he gonna do it
really does beg the question of
if we don't trust him with this with
this responsibility of a president right
cause that's all like
we can fight about who who's it should
be but um if this is a a
dually charged role of the president and
we can't trust him to do this then what
else can't we trust him to do
right in what other settings does he not
is he not someone we want to be
presidential
if we can't trust him to be the only one
with his finger on the trigger for the
nuclear buttons
do we trust him one-on-one in a room
with xi jinping or with putin yeah
i i mean again like these like and again
you know as soon as pointing out the
people who know this want to do us harm
well this is the thing the vulnerability
is there whether it's two people or not
because of joe biden
i made the shirt that i'm wearing right
now months ago and it says i'm joe biden
and i forgot this message
this sentiment was true months before
the election
it was true every time he got on stage
there's a reason they kept him in the
basement
there's a reason he didn't do many
public speaking events he does a lot of
gaffes he messes up a lot of the time
sometimes he messes up the locations
where he's actually in
yeah and that's extremely concerning for
the man that literally has his finger on
the button and could end the world with
one i want to click
make an observation it's not biden it's
a problem it's the
cognitive decline of the human brain
that's the problem and that's going to
be no matter what
yeah what's cyber biden you need to get
elon musk to neural link biting
yes just give him a tune-up could you
imagine
has an image of this yeah so the
paintings you guys see on the walls
behind everybody
is uh george oxopolis and one of his one
of his memes is biden sitting in this
chair with like a
electrode helmet attached to his head
and he's like drooling as children are
being fed to him
it's a real piece of art it's hilarious
right but uh i'm kidding we're not gonna
make cyber biden but it is a good point
the ultimate problem i see with this is
this this office is important and
powerful for
a reason right you have congress they
legislate
they're slow and nobody likes them
they're not meant to respond very very
quickly when we're being attacked the
president can declare a state of
emergency and make and take unilateral
action
and that's their excuse for like bombing
syria which is dumb because syria's not
doing anything to us
the problem is they hated trump so much
that they were like we would rather have
listen let me stop they said when donald
trump
got elected you know there's a lot of
republicans saying you're attacking the
pilot of the plane because you don't
like the way he talks over the intercom
you're going to make the plane crash
they hated trump so much because he's
flying the plane
he gets to the internet and he won't
shut up and you're like just
stop right right so that so then some
doting you know
some dotard is sitting there drooling
all over himself and like i want him to
fly the plane
and now they put this sleepy creepy joe
who's sitting in the pilot seat drooling
at himself sleeping in the planes going
yeah
and like falling down and they're like
better than the guy yelling at us for
you know the entire plane ride and right
he had two brain
aneurysms my goodness i mean
i like that yeah
yeah it's just utterly insane also the
timing of this is is very important
because this letter came out right
before
he unilaterally decided to launch
airstrikes on
syria right of course without
constitutional approval without
congressional authorization
and according to many illegal under
international law but really just
continuing the policy that barack obama
codified
in 2014 and just bombed another country
without any kind of oversight
transparency or even accountability it's
for natural gas
biden says no keystone pipeline in
america but you know what
pipeline in syria yeah see it's it's
okay
when foreign contractors go and build
gas pipelines in other countries that
were blowing up
not okay when american workers do it and
it's kind of like you know i mentioned
this before
they love outsourcing jobs they love
outsourcing factories
and then they don't want any of it here
it's almost like a not my backyard thing
oh we want the oil we want the gas but
not in my backyard even from a pipeline
right that's the other thing too this is
the richest part
yeah i know it's it's insane and like
listen it it's got to hurt of all of the
people who it probably stings for the
these strikes it has to hurt the worst
for nira tandon
who famously said that we are going to
attack libya to take the oil and now
she is seeing us attack syria for no
good reason and she's probably like her
eyes are probably lighting up with
dollar signs at the very thought of it
and yet her confirmation is going to get
railroaded because she's uh
because she tweeted a bunch of really
dumb things yeah that but also like
she's
like by all indications a bad person she
punched a reporter one time which i
don't think you're supposed to do
um and perhaps one of the one of the
most awful things
even if you just look at it the other
way that the dems see the world but i
think the way that we all see the world
too
is she um in an all staff meeting she
outed one of her employees
at cap when she worked there at the
think tank for bringing charges of
sexual harassment against their boss
and so as they were as they were talking
about it she just outed this this
this private concern and complaint um
the people the people who are who are
look man the federal government is just
a swamp yeah
and and there's like a tiny handful of
people who are stepping through the
swamp that are okay but for the most
part
it's a swamp trump did not drain the
swamp the swamp is just murkier than
ever and joe biden's back in and he is a
swamp monster yeah and think about it he
was
like he's got so many people that he's
inherited
who are former biden or obama alums
and they're like what have they been
doing for the last four years since they
left the obama white house
or well that or they've just been making
a bunch of money
working at working in washington and so
they've only gotten more swampy right
they've only cycled out and now cycle
back in we also have to acknowledge the
fact that three
last sitting presidents bombed syria
without
any congressional uh authorization the
last time donald trump did it
uh jen sackey tweeted by the way in 2017
quote also what is the legal authority
for strikes
assad is a brutal dictator but syria is
a sovereign country
gee gent yes of course he is joe biden
even
tweeted that trump was erratic impulsive
and it's the last thing a
commander-in-chief should
should do when of course donald trump
bombed syria because his daughter cried
this is the end
ivanka's ivanka trump cried to him and
told him to do it after the alleged
chemical weapons attack which there have
been some very serious questions about
and a lot of evidence countering all the
information but the big thing here we
have to understand here
is when donald trump bombed syria there
was at least some kind of
fake attempt to frame some kind of
evidence they tried they did it very
poorly
it was it was fact checked to be wrong
but now
there's no there's no evidence where's
the information where's the wmds where's
where's the justification for this that
allowed the united states to do this
they usually put on a horse and pony
show
right before launching another strike
they didn't even do that this time
they didn't say there was a threat they
didn't show any evidence they didn't
highlight anything that that could have
justified this
we still don't know thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you